I love you brother
it's like we're best friends that live
together
mom dad I've decided I want a baby
brother your store delivery service
Allison really deserves a baby brother
PS he has half named skills jr. I saved
this company by cutting out a baby's
head into package delivery Monday it'll
all be yours
barring any monumental screw-up julep
but what is that Co beans storks don't
deliver babies anymore if anyone finds
out about this I am dead meat baby
powder homing pigeon powers active eyes
was it a baby no no just a brief
exposure to baby cuteness can ruin your
life
storks this film is not yet rated
ah seriously I'm not talking to you I'm
mad at you
oh no really
I would've our this thing this tastes
like flour
okay this tiny thing is now a wolf
everybody I want to teach you to walk
around in circles yes he's poor lays
down yes yes my favorite thing to teach
you're probably asking yourself how a
stork a girl and a baby wound up in this
situation let me go back and start at
the beginning of the story
Julia you know I built my office
entirely out of class even though birds
can't see glass
I do not Power Move I'm getting out of
babies and into package delivery are you
cuckoo cuckoo you're cool Monday it'll
all be yours
barring any monumental screw-up orphan
tulip jr. a to of is just fine orphan
hers merit
that's a quail and EMU there's a chicken
they cannot find she's helping us
achieve our dreams
No what is that
dorks don't deliver babies anymore if
this baby finds her family then maybe I
can find mine you'll find your family
you think for sure this is crazy we are
delivering a baby if anyone finds out
about this I am dead meat powder baby
powder have you seen a red lady
a stork I don't know what you're talking
about I saw two that fit that
description the other day no man I will
not be a friend sorry thought we were
vibing we're gonna destroy the whole
room we have to replace the chimney with
a slide for windows store to deliver my
baby brother what he said that's a fun
mom to mean I heard that moms are fun
too
put down that baby are you in love I am
in luck are you in love I'm in love too
I agree I agree I agree I agree
we're gonna get tons of hats off this
it's an image as old as time a baby
swaddled in white delivered by the stork
how quaint but you'll find here on stork
mountain we take baby delivery seriously
I'm here to finally unveil our new and
improved human infant production
facility we have perfected and
streamlines the process devising a zero
mistake workflow trademark using the
most cutting-edge technology coupled
with over 75 years of hard-won
experience our new process has been
described as perfect precise flawless
ideal immaculate no problemo
Eric oof too big to fail the opposite of
the Titanic yes we work hard just so you
can hear the four most precious words in
human language
googoo gaga so when you're looking for
baby deliver you can come home for stork
delivery service make a fine stick to
the plans always deliver what was that
oh no my dad
Oh
here on stork Mountain we take baby
delivery seriously I'm here to finally
unveil our new and improved human infant
production facility we have perfected
and streamlined